avec le dr renoux qui est administrateur
en chef adjoint la santé publique du
canada
docteur nous bon soir au square alors
vous aviez quand même des bonnes
nouvelles aujourd'hui vous dites les
rassemblements extérieur pour cet été
entre amis avec des gens qui ne sont pas
dans la même bulle ça s'en vient
intérieur si cet automne pourquoi vous
pourquoi vous teniez à dire si
aujourd'hui vous senti qu'il faut donner
de l'espoir aux gens oui c'est très
important de donner l'espoir aux gens et
aussi parce que nous nous sommes dans
une transe dans une vraiment une bonne
position ici maintenant au canada avec
avec le déploiement des vaccins et a
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes je pense
que 50 % des adultes déjà vacciné je
pense que on continue avec avec dd pour
moi des vaccins est en moi aussi j'ai
hâte à vous reconnecter commandé plus
comme avant est ce qu'il faut surveiller
si c'est vraiment le 75% pourquoi 75%
c'est le résultat c'est un peu complexe
parce que c'est c'est un nos expertes de
modélisation qui en qui on a décrit
c'est quoi les hypothèses nécessaire
peut-être que pour avoir un site de 75%
et à des tests expliqué avec eux c'était
75% d'un de la population qui a caméra
qui a reçu au moins une dose et
peut-être aussi 20% qui ont reçu deux
doses à ce point là si on regarde aussi
qu'est ce qui se passe avec la
transmission dans les communautés si on
voit des indicateurs qui est qui
démontre que le situation est gérable
avec les les taux d'infection est aussi
un système de soins de santé à ce que la
capacité a pas débordé pour garder les
des soins c'est ans et tout ça à ce
point là je pense que les autorités à
des chaînes locales peuvent considérer
au fur et à mesure d'assouplir les
mesures de santé publique
bon et assouplir jusqu'où est ce que
quand vous dites cet automne si tout va
bien comme ça se passe pas ça se déroule
mieux qu'on croyait il faut le dire la
campagne de vaccination donc si tout se
passe bien
les rassemblements intérieure serait
permis dans votre esprit
cet automne oui parce que encore
pourquoi une note où elle aider les
personnes peuvent rentrer encore
peut-être même pour rappeler les études
des étudiants en école aussi peut-être
depuis des rassemblements à l'intérieur
je pense qu'il faut vraiment aussi
avancé avec un peu de prudence parce qu'
on est loin de d'automne maintenant mais
si tout va mieux et on espère de 75% de
la population va voir les deux doses de
vaccin et la transmission communautaire
est bien contrôlée est gérable
oui on peut voir peut-être un peu avoir
des rassemblements peut-être peur au fur
et à mesure peut-être des gros
concernées et qu'on sait mais peut-être
d d d d événements et on va voir qu'est
ce qui se passe mais ne trouve que des
mesures peut-être un moment donné on va
voir les conserves et tout ça comme
avant oui le masque parlez moi du mas
parce que vous êtes beaucoup plus
prudent à ottawa que washington les
agences de santé à washington qui a dit
qu'après deux doses
les gens pouvaient entre personnes
vaccinées par exemple on tienne réunion
qu'on pouvait enlever le masque pourquoi
vous vous n'allez pas aussi loin
les américains je pense qu'il ya eu
ils ont leur propre compte y excellent
eu raison mais si au cannet je pense que
c'est plus une approche collective et
c'est peut-être que puisse aligner avec
la presse au mama ohoua au royaume uni
et même je pense que c'est loin mais ce
qui a indiqué que c'est pas seulement
question d'être vacciné pour avoir que
le droit ou peut-être que la mission
d'enlever le port de main à paul delmas
parce que c'est aussi une question
qu'est ce qui se passe dans notre
volonté parce que on s'est vraiment deux
volets on va augmenter le taux de
vaccination vraiment avoir une bonne
comme des couvertures vaccinales
mais en même temps il faut le lire mais
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la
communauté
parce qu'avec la transmet
donc plusieurs régions dans le pays on
est encore dans donc dans un troisième
vague aussi avec des variants client que
pendant quinze ans je passe ce sera le
dernier élément de l'arsenal qu'on va
enlever dans votre esprit
c'est ça c'est ça et ça aussi c'est
aussi important de souligner le point
qu' aucune vaccin est 100% efficace donc
même avec une dose de vaccin qui donne
une production de 80 15% à l'échelle une
personne cic banque 95% efficace mais si
on parle d'une haie d'honneur d'une
perspective de la population on peut
dire que oui on peut avoir son personnes
qui sont vaccinées avec les deux dos et
peut-être que deschamps naissance et
sont exposés c'est que presque personne
peut voir encore l'infection avec la
coved 19 tonnes et il faut toujours être
prudent
oui mais on se reparlera du mas dans
quelques semaines dijon mais pour
l'instant vous dites extérieur intérieur
et éventuellement un jour peut-être le
masque merci dr hawaï où je rappelle
jette à la santé publique du canada
merci beaucoup pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit